queridos amigos Javier Miley el león de
la Argentina ya es presidente quiero
decirle a todos los argentinos que hoy
comienza el fin de la decadencia
Argentina Hoy empezamos a dar vuelta a
la página de nuestra historia y volvemos
a retomar el camino que nunca deberíamos
haber perdido hoy se termina el modelo
empobrecedor del Estado omnipresente que
solo beneficia a algunos mientras la
mayoría de los argentinos sufren damos
por terminada una larga y triste
historia de decadencia y de cbe y
comenzamos el camino de la
reconstrucción de nuestro país los
argentinos de manera contundente han
expresado una voluntad de cambio que ya
no tiene retorno no hay vuelta
atrás hoy enterramos décadas de
fracaso y sabéis queé no os quepa la
menor duda queridos amigos de que este
nuevo presidente nos dará mucho per que
mucho entretenimiento tanto que A este
paso en visual politic vamos a tener que
plantearnos seriamente mudarnos a la
propia Argentina no os parece El caso es
que en vídeos anteriores ya os hemos
hablado de muchas de las reformas que ha
prometido mi ley para transformar de
arriba a abajo el país gaucho sin
embargo su Revolución política no se
queda solo en casa Pekín sería gran
error para mi lei cortar lazos con china
Lula sobre Javier Miley podría implicar
un retroceso de 40 años ha ganado la
extrema derecha en Argentina es la
decisión de su sociedad triste para
América Latina y ya veremos el
neoliberalismo ya no tiene propuesta
para la sociedad no puede responder a
los problemas actuales de la humanidad
es un día triste para el bloque
democrático en todo el mundo mucho ánimo
al pueblo argentino que hoy siente
incertidumbre y miedo Miley no solo se
ha convertido en un desafío para todo el
establishment local argentino sino
también para muchos de los países que
han tratado de estrechar lazos con la
casa rosada en la última década por eso
y dado que estamos en un canal de
política internacional creo que en esta
ocasión tenemos que responder a unas
cuantas preguntas Cuál será exactamente
la política exterior de Javier Miley Qué
opinión tienen China y estado Estados
Unidos de su llegada al poder qué
intereses están en juego llegaremos a
ver la salida de Argentina del mercosur
Pues bien todo esto y más lo vamos a ver
a continuación gasolina y arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Buenos Aires es una ciudad tan Pasional
como Rebelde y ojo porque no lo digo por
su mundialmente conocido carácter gaucho
sino también por la propia política
exterior de este país en los últimos 50
años Argentina ha jugado en el mundo un
rol de blanco o negro pero nunca una
posición neutral por ejemplo en los años
80 en plena dictadura militar el régimen
argentino se negó a sumarse a los
diferentes embargos de grano que Estados
Unidos impuso contra la unión soviética
y eso a pesar de que el dictador Videla
y sus Sucesores siempre se jactaban de
estar llevando a cabo una lucha contra
el marxismo Internacional ya sabéis
cuestión de negocio en esa misma etapa
Buenos Aires se metió además en una
guerra abierta contra el mismísimo Reino
Unido estamos por supuesto hablando de
la guerra de las malvinas en 1983 pero
no penséis que ahí termina todo tan solo
7 años después y ya en democracia
Argentina participó activamente de la
ejecución de las resoluciones del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
impulsados por Estados Unidos contra
Irak en 1990 Y sí vale No es que tuviera
una contribución especialmente relevante
pero apoyó la guerra y envió un
destructor y tres corbetas a la zona
para hacer operaciones de patrullaje
posteriormente hacia 2005 Néstor kisner
como anfitrión de la Cumbre de las
Américas celebrada en el mar de la plata
fue uno de los líderes políticos que
acabaron con el alca el área de libre
comercio de las Américas que proponía
Estados Unidos y que fue una de las
grandes iniciativas de George bos aquí
en mar del plata está la tumba del
[Música]
[Aplausos]
alca alca alca al
Argentina Quizá no es una potencia
militar ni tampoco un enclave político
esencial ni un emirato del petróleo
Aunque mucho ojo con vaca muerta pero de
una forma u otra siempre se las arregla
para estar metido en todos los follones
de la región y sabéis qué Parece que eso
no va a cambiar mucho con la llegada de
Javier Miley a la casa rosada trabajando
en armar una estrategia para enfrentar
la izquierda a nivel internacional y una
de las posibilidades que también estamos
elaborando es la posibilidad de hacer un
una suerte de congreso de la derecha
digamos entendida en el sentido como se
piensa en términos políticos eh en
Argentina en cualquier caso Argentina es
el segundo país más grande de Sudamérica
con una relevante proyección territorial
sobre la antártida y un cúmulo de rutas
marítimas entre los océanos Atlántico
sur y Pacífico Sur hablamos de rutas
como el estrecho de Magallanes el canal
de beigel o el pasaje de Drake que hacen
que su posición internacional tenga
cierto interés algo que por cierto
explica noticias como esta El Comando
sur de Estados Unidos alertó por la base
espacial china en Argentina más tarde
hablaremos de esto pero por ahora la
pregunta es Qué significa exactamente la
llegada de milei a la presidencia
Quiénes serán sus aliados y sus enemigos
en el escenario internacional y qué
podemos esperar de él pues bien hoy en
visual politic os lo contamos todo
atentos
se viene el rearme
argentino queridos amigos aquí en visual
politic lo hemos comentado en varias
ocasiones pero sabéis qué nunca nunca
está de más ponernos en situación en
Argentina las fuerzas armadas son un
tema muy delicado Esto es así porque
durante el siglo XX entre los años 1930
y 1976 los militares dieron seis golpes
de estado el ciclo militar se cerró en
1983 con miles de desap parecidos y una
dolorosa derrota bélica esta situación
hizo que en democracia la relación entre
los civiles y los militares fuera
relativamente tensa no tengo miedo ni
les tengo miedo que queremos el ejército
de San Martín belgrano mosconi y sabio y
no de aquellos que asesinaron a sus
propios hermanos que fueron de
Videla viola y des los años 9 forma de
debilitar la posición de los uniformados
fue recortando su presupuesto
fijaos hacia
1988 en la última etapa del gobierno de
Raúl alfonsín Argentina Era uno de los
países con mayor gasto militar per
cápita de toda la región pero ahora es
el peor en esta categoría la diferencia
por ejemplo con chile es
[Música]
enorme por supuesto con la que está
cayendo en Argentina no parece que las
fuerzas armadas puedan ni deban ser una
prioridad sin embargo pese a todo en
2020 el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
creó el conocido como fondo Nacional de
la defensa este fondo tiene como
objetivo financiar el reequipamiento de
las fuerzas armadas argentinas con un
capital fijo mínimo del 0,8 por del
presupuesto público anual hablamos al
menos de unos 800 millones de dólares
por año y qué piensa sobre esto el nuevo
presidente pues lo cierto Es que Javier
Miley en principio está a favor de la
modernización y actualización del
equipamiento militar argentino al menos
eso es lo que ha dicho hasta ahora el
factor moral de las fuerzas está
fuertemente afectado Y el personal sufre
una acentuada frustración vocacional
luego de años de agravios por ello
proponemos crear un instrumento militar
ágil moderno y tecnológicamente avanzado
que reemplace las actuales estructuras
obsoletas financiar adecuadamente la
defensa nacional para revertir el
deficiente estado de equipamiento e
instrucción así que ya lo veis las
fuerzas armadas son uno de esos raras
Avis donde parece existir un gran
consenso entre los políticos argentinos
el problema es Quién será el proveedor
de los nuevos equipos ojo con esta
pregunta por ejemplo los planes actuales
contemplan la compra de lanchas de
patrullaje la modernización de vehículos
mecanizados así como la adquisición de
nuevos radares y diversos tipos de
munición Sin embargo El plato más jugoso
está en el cielo me estoy refiriendo por
supuesto a la modernización de los
aviones de
combate Argentina Quiere modernizar sus
viejos cazas que en su mayoría forman
parte de generaciones utilizadas durante
la Guerra de malvinas y mira que ha
llovido desde entonces en este sentido
el gobierno de Alberto Fernández recibió
varias ofertas las dos principales
tienen que ver con los jf1 Thunder
chinos y los f16 norteamericanos en este
último caso f16 de segunda mano que
podrían proceder de Dinamarca
naturalmente ahora que conocemos las
opciones podemos comprender
perfectamente el trasfondo geopolítico
que esta decisión conlleva pensad que
cada una de estas ofertas no solo
comprende el propio avión de combate
sino también sus repuestos simuladores
misiles y el entrenamiento militar es
decir hablamos de un paquete que por sí
mismo podría vincular a largo plazo a la
fuerza aérea Argentina con Estados
Unidos China o la
India Pues bien en la 63 conferencia de
jefes de las fuerzas aéreas de América
que tuvo lugar el pasado mes de julio de
2023 los comandantes de las alas
argentinas mostraron abiertamente su
preferencia por los f16 y de hecho en
octubre Washington dio su visto bueno a
la operación Estados Unidos autorizó una
venta de aviones f16 a la Argentina el
departamento dio luz verde para realizar
una transferencia de 24 aeronaves de
Dinamarca la transacción compite con una
oferta de China sin embargo el problema
con la compra de muchos equipos
occidentales tiene que ver con Londres
la resistencia del Reino Unido a la
modernización y El Avance militar
argentinos puso Argentina en manos de
China argentina se comprometió con china
en 2021 a evaluar los cazas jf1 chino
pakistaníes los jf1 son asequibles y de
Gran valor para Argentina principalmente
porque no están sujetos a las sanciones
del Reino Unido Y es que veréis el
embargo que Reino Unido mantiene sobre
la comercialización de armas a la
Argentina limita las aspiraciones de la
casa rosada de no levantar Londres este
bloqueo ningún equipo militar puede
tener componentes británicos y el
problema es que hay algunos equipos que
sí los tienen precisamente por eso la
Casa Blanca está intentando triangular
un acuerdo entre el 10 de downing Street
y la casa rosada para evitar que al
final la opción más lógica sea china a
la hora de comprar
[Música]
armamento sea como sea Respecto a los
cazas parece que al final la opción de
los f16 daneses de segunda mano será la
preferida ya sabéis que mi ley ha dicho
por activa y por pasiva que el nuevo
presidente argentino no estará dispuesto
bajo ningún concepto a vincularse
militarmente con la República popular
china Claro que veremos si estos aviones
finalmente se compra porque tal y como
se encuentran en las finanzas argentinas
qué queréis que os diga el gasto militar
no parece precisamente una prioridad en
cualquier caso no se trata solo de los
aviones a medio y largo plazo la
elección del proveedor militar
preferente tendrá muchas implicaciones
políticas por supuesto china quiere
quedarse con este puesto a toda Costa
Pero sabéis qué la llegada de milei no
solo parece enviar al traste esa
posibilidad sino que además es posible
que estemos ante la mejor oportunidad
para que en cierta forma se alivie la
tensión que Todavía existe entre Londres
y Buenos Aires fijaos por ejemplo en
esta noticia Diana mondino sobre
malvinas los isleños tienen los mismos
derechos que cualquier argentino negar
eso Es ridículo Diana mondino no es
cualquier voz hablamos de la nueva
ministra de asuntos exteriores de Javier
Miley y es que queridos amigos ya no
solo hablamos de un tema económico sino
también de un tema geopolítico Reino
Unido sigue siendo sumamente estricto
con el embargo post malvinas contra el
Argentina Pero por otra parte Miley ha
dejado Claro que no mantendrá relaciones
proactivas con china con lo que su
inclinación por el armamento occidental
es algo que se da por hecho mejorarán
las cosas lo suficiente entre Londres y
Buenos Aires para que eso sea realmente
posible desde luego podemos estar ante
la mejor oportunidad desde
1982 Y mira que ha llovido sea como sea
este tema va mucho más allá porque
aunque sea por otros caminos buenos aire
se encuentra ahora entre Pekín y
[Música]
Washington cuentos chinos y la sombra de
Trump queridos amigos la Cruzada de
Javier Miley contra la casta trasciende
fronteras en el exterior Ya ha dejado
claro que el comunismo Será su gran
enemigo la llegada de milei a la casa
rosada parece volar en mil pedazos las
relaciones tanto con Rusia como con
China y sabéis que en lo que respecta al
gigante asiático son muchos los
intereses que están en riesgo y es que
en los últimos años la vinculación de
china con Argentina ha sido clave para
su desembarco en América Latina fijaos
el abrazo de Argentina a China Debería
ser una llamada de atención Argentina es
un ejemplo paradigmático de cómo América
Latina se está orientando hacia el este
para satisfacer sus necesidades
económicas y de desarrollo lo que
posiblemente la encamine a hacia una
trayectoria centrada en China en los
años venideros argentina se sumó a la
nueva ruta de la seda y obtiene un
millonario financiamiento con esta esta
decisión estratégica el gobierno
nacional rubricar diferentes acuerdos
que garantizan financiamiento para
inversiones y Obras por más de
23,700 millones de dólares generando un
nuevo hito en la relación bilateral que
en los últimos 15 años se amplió y
fortaleció notablemente de hecho la
cooperación entre ambos países llegó a
tal punto que en agosto de 2022 se
filtró un memorándum entre el gobierno
provincial de Tierra de Fuego y la
empresa china shanchi Chemical Industry
Group para la construcción de un polo
petroquímico que contará con una
terminal por suárea multipropósito
además china mantiene en Argentina la
estación del espacio
lejano desde esta estación los gobiernos
de Argentina y la República popular
china brindan soporte de telemetría
seguimiento control de las misiones del
programa chino para exploración de la
luna y varios otros programas de
investigación científica sobre el
espacio la relevancia de este tipo de
programas ha estado incrementándose
tanto que china ya resalta su papel a
nivel oficial lo de Pekín y Buenos Aires
era un romance en ascenso que ya hacía
ruido hasta en lond
Argentina es una de las muchas piezas
del plan chino para Sudamérica china
pretende desarrollar una base militar en
bata Guinea ecuatorial bata comparte las
mismas ventajas que Ascensión tuvo para
el Reino Unido durante la Guerra de las
malvinas una cooperación más estrecha
entre China y Argentina permitirá a la
armada del ejército Popular de
liberación imponer mayores costes de
defensa al Reino Unido para defender las
malvinas lo que podría alejar a su
naciente fuerza de portaaviones de
ataque y submarinos del apoyo a las
operaciones de Estados Unidos la otan y
el indop Pacífico pero ahora el amor
está a punto de llegar a su final mile
ha dejado Claro que alineará su política
con Estados Unidos e Israel y que
enfrentará e incluso romperá relaciones
con gobiernos comunistas Claro que
tampoco es que le caiga particularmente
bien la actual administración de Joe
biden fijaos en lo que decía cuando este
llegó a la casa blanca los demócratas
empezaron a buscar censurar antes de
ingresar ahora hablan de perseguir a los
libertarios porque son inadaptados que
no les gusta el estado desde luego ya os
digo yo que el sentimiento es
recíproco en Washington muchos Ven a
milei como una especie de Little Trump
entre otras cosas porque muchos medios
norteamericanos y varios políticos
republicanos se han encargado de forjar
esa imagen pese a todas las diferencias
políticas que existen entre Miley y
Trump y de la que por cierto ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visual potic un
libertario de extrema derecha gana las
primarias presidenciales en Argentina
los republicanos descubren al libertario
Miley y Ted Cruz lo promueve como
ejemplo para los candidatos de su
partido por si fuera poco en 2021 el
mismo Mire respaldaba las tesis de
fraude electoral y justificaba el asalto
al Capitolio de Washington porque hay
muchos testimonios de que digamos la
hubo ciertas irregularidades Si por algo
la gente está así no es que digamos sea
esto no es que fue organizado
eh Dio para que la gente vaya a eso digo
la gente digamos o sea cuando se siente
estafada digamos actúa de maneras que
uno no lo puede explicar Así que tampoco
es que en el Washington actual m vaya a
encontrar muchos amigos es posible que
lo vean como un mal menor frente a China
pero la relación probablemente no vaya
mucho más allá Claro que si hablamos de
política exterior y de Javier Miley
Tenemos que hablar sobre todo y por
encima de todo de mercosur Y por qué
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
[Música]
verit El Fin Del
mercosur
desde los años 90 Argentina está
comprometida con el mercado común del
sur mercosur Una Unión adera en la que
también encontramos a Brasil Uruguay y
Paraguay mercosur amigos es una
organización que todo se ha dicho tras
tres décadas funcionando no ha dado los
frutos que se esperaban de ella ni de
lejos mercosur ha sido incapaz de
avanzar en la liberación del comercio ni
siquiera ha podido eliminar aranceles
internos Así que imaginaos el desastre
que es cuando hablamos del resto del
mundo de hecho muchas veces más que una
organización por comercio es una
organización antic comercio por ejemplo
mercosur ha impedido que por ahora sus
países miembros puedan firmar acuerdos
de libre comercio con terceros países
que es por ejemplo lo que Uruguay quiere
hacer con china Pues bien con semejante
escenario el plan motosierra de milei al
menos insisto el publicado hasta la
fecha no pretende abrir un debate dentro
del mercosur para intentar reformarlo
poco a poco sino que lo que plantea
directamente es su eliminación yo creo
que hay que eliminar el mercosur porque
es una Unión aduanera defectuosa que
perjudica a los argentinos de bien o sea
es en el fondo es un comercio
administrado por Estados para favorecer
empresarios prendarios Y es que el
problema que tienen los libertarios como
mercosur no solo se limita a una
cuestión económica o comercial sino que
también afecta al propio debate
ideológico que plantea la libertad
avanza para mi ley cualquier
acercamiento a gobiernos socialistas es
inaceptable por lo que compartir bloque
y tener que negociar y pactar con el
Brasil de Lula Pues no estaría dentro de
sus mejores planes yo soy un defensor de
la libertad de la paz y de la Democracia
los comunistas no entran ahí los chinos
no entran ahí ahí Putin no entra ahí
digamos Lula no entra ahí Es decir
nosotros queremos ser el faro moral del
continente quizás al final pase lo mismo
que con bullrich Al fin y al cabo
hablamos de un mercado importante para
Argentina de dos mercados importantes y
también tenemos en cuenta a
China entre el 30 y el 25% de todas las
exportaciones argentinas tienen como
destino el mercosur o China y si bien
los vínculos podrían proseguir con el
sector privado romper los acuerdos
vigentes en el mercosur obligaría a
llevar a cabo toda una reestructuración
de los trámites y procesos comerciales
que seguro entorpecer los flujos
comerciales durante un tiempo y respecto
a China Bueno ya sabéis lo aficionados
que son en Pekín a castigar el comercio
con aquellos países que no le son leales
es lo que se llama la política del lobo
Guerrero de la que ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visual
politics sea como sea ojo con que Miley
cumpla su palabra Claro que insisto no
nos engañemos también puede ocurrir que
pase lo mismo que con bullrich que de
ser casta y una montonera tirabombas
pasó a ser una estrecha aliada Al fin y
al cabo tanto macri como bolsonaro
tuvieron buenas relaciones tanto con
Washington como con Moscú y Pekín
pragmatismo por encima de todo La
pregunta es hará lo mismo milei se
marcará un Pedro Sánchez ya sabéis eso
de cambie de opinión no lo sabemos pero
de momento lo que se ha prometido el
nuevo presidente es ser tajante con este
tema y de hecho ha dejado muy pero que
muy claro que se retirará de los bricks
Javier Miley también rechazó el ingreso
de Argentina a los bricks no voy a
impulsar un trato con comunistas desde
luego si mantiene su palabra mi ley
puede sembrar todo un precedente no está
claro si para bien o para mal pero sería
algo completamente
nuevo amigos si algo está claro es que
fuera de Argentina la libertad avanza y
milei no dejan indiferentes a nadie o lo
aman o lo odian ni siquiera el papa que
es argentino escapa esta Cruzada esum es
un un Papa Don donde tiene fuerte
injerencia política ha demostrado además
una gran afinidad con dictadores así que
ya lo veis podemos esperar una Argentina
mucho más volcada a occidente Pero hay
muchos temas que veremos Cómo se
resuelven si milei cumple su palabra
creo que va a dar mucho de que hablar
también en lo que respecta a su política
exterior en visual politic estaremos muy
atentos pero ahora el turno ya no es mío
ahora es para ti qué te parece la
postura que Hasta ahora ha tenido Javier
Miley crees que la mantendrá en la casa
rosada qué es lo que harías Tú mismo
Pues déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y habramos debate y ahora si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle a like y suscribirte a
visual politics si es que todavía no lo
has hecho muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima